>> So, let's start.
Professor Vyas Sekar
is associate Professor
at CMU EC department.
He's part of the CyLab
and Conic Center.
He works in networks and
security and he's talking
about Universal Monitoring
and Universal Sketching.
>> All right. Thank you.
Thanks for having me
this summer school,
seems like some fun
process are going on.
So, this is actually
based on a talk I gave
recently at ECM staff,
which is surprising that they
invited a systems person
to a theory conference.
So, this is actually
an interesting story
of serendipitous collaboration
between theory and systems.
We'd originally started
off doing it in
the context of
network monitoring,
but thinking more broadly,
I actually think that this type
of work has broader applications
to telemetry and analytics
and whatever kind of
monitoring we want to do
in future IoT systems.
Before I begin actually,
I want to thank
a lot of people who actually
did most of this work.
I'm just here as
an evangelist for this work.
The original universal
monitoring team Alan Liu,
who is a student
at Johns Hopkins,
and his advisers
Vladimir Braverman,
who's behind most of
this theoretical breakthroughs
in universal sketching.
We've also done a lot
of implementations
to show that it's not
just theory but
there's also a lot of
practical implementations
on different platforms.
So, there's a bunch of
folks who have helped
us do these things.
All right. So, let's dive
in to the motivation
for this work.
So, the motivation for
this work really stems
from the fact that,
if you are managing
a large network system,
an IoT system for example,
you actually have a whole
different slew of analytics,
tasks that you actually want
to run on top of the system.
So, for example, I may want to
estimate what kind of
traffic is going
through the network,
I might want to estimate
different properties of the
data through my network;
I might want to check for
different kinds of anomalies.
Has there been a spike
in a particular region?
Are there new heavy-hitters
while sending a lot of traffic,
and so on, and so forth?
So, these are
the analytics tasks that I
might be interested
in a network setting.
Now, here's a very informal
problem definition
of what I would like to do.
So, imagine an IoT deployment
or network deployment,
I have a bunch of
different telemetry
on monitoring applications,
and notice that the very fact
that I'm doing monitoring,
means that many of these tasks
might be unforeseen.
I may not know until
the deployment happens or
until the system is actually
running of what I'm looking for.
Obviously, this problem is
trivial if there are no
resource constraints.
The key factors in a network
or an IoT deployment,
there are key
resource constraints on
your elements that are
monitoring the state
of your system.
So, these could be either CPU,
or memory constraint, or
bandwidth constraint,
and reporting the statistics
to a central agent or
in an IoT setting,
things like energy that becomes
very important as well.
So, generic problem is
really deciding what
monitoring primitives
do I want to run on my sensors,
on my monitors, on
my network routers,
and so on, such that they
respect these
resource constraints.
They operate within
the system parameters but still
provide high-fidelity
estimates or
provide high accuracy for the
applications I care about.
That if I actually
wanted to detect
an attack or detect if there is
a spike in energy usage in
a particular
environment and so on,
I do want to
provide high accuracy
for those applications.
Alright. So, this is
the driving question
for this work is what
monitoring primitives
do I want it on?
Now, again, I'm going
to use networking
as a driving application
or a driving scenario,
but you can think this has more
broader applications as well.
So, the traditional approach
you would think about doing
this is as data comes to
you in a streaming model,
the very simplest thing
you can do is just run
a uniform sampling algorithm,
and then collect the data,
and then send it to
some central agent
for running estimates
on top of that.
So, for example, in the context
of network monitoring,
the most common used primitive
today is something
called Netflow,
or Cflow, or
other industry terms.
So what it does is it
samples the incoming
packets at random,
groups packets with
the similar pattern
into what are called flows,
and then reports these flows and
their counters to
some central collection point.
So, here's a quick animation.
You have different flows here;
flows one, three, and six.
Flow one has five packets,
flow three as one packet, flow
six has one packet, and so on.
As these items come
through the system,
this monitor is sampling
then discarding some
of the samples,
updating contours for
a subset of these,
and then it reports
whatever it sampled.
The sample flow reports to
some central agent and then I
can estimate different properties
of the stream that I wanted to
monitor using the sample
reports I've collected.
So, this is a very
typical workflow that
happens in most
monitoring tasks today.
Now, the problem is and
many people have observed it
is sampling is
a reasonable starting point,
but it is actually not great for
a number of fine-grained tasks.
For example, if I wanted
to do anomaly detection,
or some security monitoring,
or finding the heavy hitter
that's in the network,
sampling may actually not
give you the right answer.
Now, an alternative approach,
and there's been a lot of
really cool theoretical work
in this space is what are called
sketching or
streaming algorithms.
So, in a general workflow
here is think about, it is like,
if you tell me what metric
you are interested in,
like saying, I want to find
the maximum value
of a data stream,
or I want to find the median
value of a data stream,
or I want to find the percentiles
of these values in a data stream,
and so on, if you tell
me the metric a priori,
there are a number of very cool,
compact, highly
efficient algorithms,
or sketching algorithms
that can maintain
a compressed data
structure that are
extremely optimized for
monitoring that
particular metric.
So, if I say, "I want
to find heavy-hitters,
I want to find the
entropy of this stream,
I want to detect people
talking to a number
of destinations,
and so on, and so forth,
I can actually go and develop
these custom algorithms deployed
them on my monitoring nodes,
collect the data structures
relevant for that particular
monitoring tasks,
and then report them back."
So, there's been a lot
of fascinating theory
in this literature that
solve these problems.
Now, of course, from a practical
systems point of view,
imagine you're
developing an IoT sensor
or an IoT monitoring system,
this is not attainable or
a practical trajectory.
The set of metrics
I care about in
the stream is always
constantly growing,
and I also don't know if
priori what metrics I
want to monitor
the state of my network.
So, clearly from
a systems point of view,
this is not a great idea
because it entails
higher complexity on your sensor
with limited compute
and bandwidth.
It's obviously
higher development time
like everyone of us
has to go develop
new algorithms as new applications
emerge, and moreover,
even if you think about
a re-programmable or
a re-flashable sensor that you
can actually change
the algorithms running on it.
Even that is not sufficient
because at any given
point of time,
the resources on
that node have been
tightly committed to the metric
of interest already.
If I want to do some retroactive
analysis and ask, "Hey,
what was the value of this metric
in one five minutes ago?"
Unless that metric was
already being monitored,
I actually don't know that value.
So, it's not very good
for time series analysis,
or attractive forensics,
and so on, and so forth.
So, this dilemma,
this two classes of
estimation approaches,
generic approaches
like sampling which
are okay but not very accurate,
or custom algorithms
that are highly
accurate but entail
a lot of complexity.
From a systems point of
view, this question has
been bugging people
for a long time.
Interestingly, the same problem
has also been bugging
the theory community.
So, the theory community is
asking a similar question in
this open question from
a theory workshop on
this question of,
"Is there a vision for a
universal sketching solution?"
That is, rather than commit
your sketch to a single function,
is it possible to define
these sketching
primitives that are
generic across a wide range
of possible functions?
So, this is an open
question back in 2011,
and people didn't
really know there is
an answer to this
question, and so on.
So, based on the ideal vision
that we want for developing
a robust monitoring
infrastructure
for future IoT deployments
and future deployments,
it's what I would call the vision
for universal monitoring.
The idea here is
as you're stream of data
goes through
your monitoring node,
I can do some amount
of data processing in
a streaming fashion.
I want to keep as generic
a computation or
a data structure as
possible on what I call
the monitoring data plane,
the hardware, the IoT sensors.
I report this generic or
compressed data structure
back to some central
collection agents,
so something in the management
or control plane.
The idea and the hope is that
whatever I am collecting
can be used for
a variety of downstream
applications or task.
Somebody else can go write
queries on top of this compressed
data structure and say,
"I want to re-estimate
or recover properties
at the stream that my
application really cares about."
So, again this is
one data structure for
a wide variety of tasks,
and the nice thing is actually
naturally what I would
call Late-binding,
and this is a nice
property to have
from a systems perspective,
is that when I
deploy this sensor,
build this hardware,
investment my
developer's time and
deploying these algorithms,
I do not need to know a priori
what my customers want.
So, this is actually a
very powerful, practical,
architecture I do not
need to know what
the customer wants before
deploying them out there
in the real world.
So, this is a crazy vision.
I mean, it's not clear
how I can do it,
so it's obviously a bunch of
different technical challenges
in this problem space
that we actually
don't know the answers
to at this time.
So, a bunch of open questions.
First of all, there's
this theoretical question of does
a universal sketch
actually exist?
This is an open question, does
the sketch actually exist?
Even if it does,
it may be impractical
to implement.
So what's the point of having
a theoretically elegant algorithm
if it's not very practical to
implement on
a resource constraint,
a hardware, or a router,
and so on? Yeah.
>> What is the definition
of a universal sketch?
>> So, the definition of
universal sketch is exactly this.
You give me a set of functions,
or set of metrics,
or applications you want to run.
I have to put one single
counting data structure on
my monitor such that
all of those applications
will have high accuracy.
>> But I thought your example
was come up an application
in the future?
>> Correct.
>> And the.
>> Exactly.
So, the setup applications might
be unknown or unforeseen,
but you may bound them and
say they may come from
this family of
functions and so on.
We will qualify what that
universality means in a second.
But think about the way
there are any number
of tasks that
a future network operator or
a future IoT analytics framework
may think about,
and the counters and keeping
should be sufficient to
estimate that
particular application.
Sorry. So, again,
the idea there is you have
resource constraints.
They don't have
infinite memory, They
don't have infinite processing.
So, it has to be
a compact data structure.
Sorry? So, typically,
the sketching and
the streaming algorithms
are sub-linear
in terms of the number
of items in the stream,
and I'll define
the streaming problem
a little bit better.
Obviously, fired like
infinite things,
I would dump all the data,
send out the data.
But that means that I'm
violating the CPU consumption,
the memory consumption, and
the communication cost.
That's not a viable option for
IoT routers or
anything in practice.
So, the first question is,
does a universal sketch exist?
Before I go there,
I should give a little bit of
background to formally define
what I mean by a sketching
or a streaming algorithm,
and again, I'm going
to use some of
the standard terminology from
the theory community to explain
what these problems are.
So, here's a very quick
one-slide overview
of what a stream or a
sketching algorithm means.
So, you have a data stream.
A stream is of length m,
say the number of
packets or the number
of sensor readings
that you're getting,
and there are n
unique items, say,
unique IP addresses or
unique values of
energy readings and so on.
So, I want to use
a small amount of memory,
in terms of the size
of the stream.
I want to use something like
sublinear in m or n. Sketches are
essentially a class of
these data-stream summaries
that intuitively do
some kind of hash-based
computation or
some compressed data
structure of the stream.
So, one way to think about
it, say for example,
at least for me intuitively is,
zero to order problem is
checking whether you
saw this item before.
So, this Bloom filter, you
can think of as a sketch.
It's a very simple sketch
that lets you do set
membership queries
without actually
having to store every
item you've seen so far.
So, think about sketches
or data streams,
streaming algorithms
are extensions
to a Bloom filter approach,
a data structure that
also lets you do
volumetric or counting queries,
not just membership queries.
Again, it's very loose
hand-wavy way of
thinking about a sketch.
If you've never seen
a sketch before,
think of it as like some sort of
a Bloom filter plus
counting capabilities.
There are actually a lot of
seminal theory results that
talk about the feasibility of
doing these kind of computations
for different kinds
of metrics of interest
on your screen.
One of the earliest
request was in '85,
the AMS paper in '96 actually won
the Golden Prize in Theoretical
Computing. All right.
So, typically, in the standard
sketching formulation,
the way the theory has progressed
is you define
a particular metric,
say for example, I want to
find the number of
unique items in a stream,
I want to find
the first order moment,
I want to find the second moment
of a stream, and so on.
So, given a particular metric,
there's a particular
sketch that is
probably optimal in
terms of the memory,
accuracy, trade-offs
for that particular
metric of interest.
So, I have one algorithm
that solves one problem,
and that is the classical
way of thinking
about sketching or
streaming algorithms.
Now, universality or
universal question,
universal streaming I'm
asking here, and again,
going back to your question
about what do I mean
by universality,
this is a little bit of
a restricted version
of universality,
which is that if you think
about the frequency vector,
which is the frequency of item i,
many of the existing sketches
I think about is you
can write them as either
summation of f_i squared,
summation f_i cubed,
summation f_i or f_i log,
f_i, and so on, and so forth.
There are some functions
of the frequency vector.
Now, we are asking,
universality is really about
can I estimate an arbitrary G,
summation of the G of f_i?
Some G function
that I don't know,
but I'm restricted
to this class of
functions where G
comes in this form.
Let my function is of this form,
expressed as a summation
of the frequency vectors.
So, this is a classic,
this is theoretical
formulation of it.
So, one of the things we've
found is many things that we
actually want in practice,
actually mapped to that.
So, I have to think about,
whether the particular
function you're thinking
about can be mapped into
this particular things.
Actually, I tell you
the theoretical result.
So, then we can see
whether, it actually
fits that particular form or not,
or maybe there's
an approximate version
of the function
you're writing that
actually might be
mapping to that.
But, that's actually
a very good open question,
which I don't know.
It's like if you have
an application in mind,
does it fit my model?
That I don't know,
I can't just give you
an intuitive answer as like,
"Hey, this is there or not."
So, here's an example,
you can write this,
many of the classical sketches
like first-order,
unique elements,
entropy sketches,
all of them can be
written in this form,
as some kind of G-sum function.
So, and this is where
this somewhat
counter-intuitive result.
In theory, that
actually says that
indeed there exists
a universal approach or
a universal data structure
or a universal sketch
that can support a very
large family of functions.
So, these are class of
functions that intuitively don't
grow faster than f_i squared.
So, if the function
does not grow faster,
monotonically faster
than f_i squared,
it turns out there is
a universal sketch
construction for
that particular class
of functions.
The theory that's
an extra bit universality proof,
and then the existential proof
is like there is
a universal sketch that
exists that actually
can be used to estimate
this G-sum with
high probability using
polylogarithmic memory,
again, sublinear memory in
terms of the stream size.
Now, again, I did not
come up with this theory,
it was really cool theory,
and probably beyond
my comprehension,
but it's actually
a very counter-intuitive
and interesting result that shows
the feasibility of developing
a universal construction for
a large family of functions.
Again, as I said,
many things we cared about in
the network setting seemed to
fit this definition
very naturally.
>> So, one option is to just keep
every f_i [inaudible] usually?
>> As a sketch, yeah.
>> So, I assume that this
does better than that?
>> Actually, you'll see
some other results,
I think one of the nice things of
universality is actually
this late binding,
and I don't need
to know it prior,
that what is necessary,
and also the nice thing
also we'll see is actually
that it's better to
give more memory,
the union of the memory to
like a universal sketch,
than fragment your resources
across multiple sketches.
So, one of the the subset
from both systems and
theoretical perspectives
is actually interesting,
actually says that we'll
see as the portfolio grows,
it's better to give the resources
to a universal sketch and
fragment it across
custom sketches
for each different application.
Again, this G can be more
than just f_i, f_i squared.
It can be a little bit
more broader than that.
So, here is the intuitively
I've requested a theory,
people to explain this
to me a little bit
more intuitively.
Intuitively, the way
to think about it is
it goes back to
classical heavy hitters.
Heavy hitters are items
in the stream that
appear a lot of times,
say the one person
who's getting the dust,
or the one person that's
sending a lot of traffic,
or heavy hitters in your stream.
Now, intuitively,
you can essentially
split the stream into two cases,
either there is indeed
one very large g-heavy hitter,
not a heavy hitter in
the classical sense,
but a heavy hitter that
contributes to the G-sum.
In which case, you can use
a classical heavy hitter
algorithm and you're done.
You basically get a very
accurate estimate of the G-sum,
if you just find
the heavy hitters,
the L2 heavy hitters.
L2 here, the L2
norm of the stream.
Now, the second case
is more interesting.
It's actually suppose the
stream is such that there is
no such sufficiently
large heavy hitter
that's contributing
a significant amount of mass,
then there is this trick
where you can
actually think about
running the recursive version of
this on progressively
smaller sampled substreams,
and in fact that's a logarithmic
number of substreams,
and it turns out you can actually
prove that finding heavy hitters
on recursively sampled streams
is sufficient to
estimate the G-sum.
So, again, this is
a very hand-wavy explanation of
why universal sketching
actually works.
So, let me actually show you what
the data structure
actually looks like.
So, what we're going to
do is, given a stream,
we're going to use a number
of a logarithmic number
of zero-one hash
functions, essentially,
say whether or not
this particular item
in the stream is being sampled.
So, I've leveled like level zero,
level one dot, dot,
dot until level log(n),
and at every level,
I'm going to run
a classical heavy hitter sketch.
So, this can be
Count-Min, Count-Sketch,
any number of algorithms that you
can plug-in and play here.
So, any number of
classical heavy hitter
algorithms can be plugged
in to this framework that
does L2 heavy hitters.
Then, I get the heavy hitters
and their respective counters
from every level,
and it turns out that
it's sufficient to get
a very accurate estimate of
a G-sum through
a recursive computation. Now.
So, this is actually what the,
intuitively, the data
structure looks like.
If you think about
our original vision of
universal monitoring, really,
what we're going to do is put
this sampling and sketch
counting heavy-hitter sketches
in our data plane.
So, there's a bunch of
hash function computations
and these sketching counters.
I'm going to push
all the application
specific computation, say,
I want to do data detection,
I want to find the top
K people in the stream,
I want to estimate the entropy of
a particular dimension and so on,
I'm going to push all
of those into what
I would call the
logical control plane,
some sort of analytics agent,
or a cloud back-end or whatever.
So, all these, in
some sense are offline.
Think about all the application
specific computation.
That means they may
still be real-time,
but they're not running
on the IoT sensor itself,
they're running in
some back-end agent. Yeah.
>> [inaudible].
>> Great question. So, we'll
get to that in a little bit.
So, you can think about
it that way as well.
But that's actually one
of the things where
the "theory meets
the practice" has
to be a little bit more careful,
and we give you examples
where, in some cases,
memory is the bottleneck,
and then in that case, that's
the right thing to do.
In some cases where processing
or CPU becomes the bottleneck,
you may have to come
up with alternatives
or approximations to
that particular login-
the hash computation itself.
In fact, we have found
that in some cases.
I'll tell you about
that. All right,
so this comes back to your
prefetching the second question.
Okay, I've told you
the universal sketch
construction at a high level,
is it actually
practical to implement?
I don't yet have
experience implementing
on low-power IoT platforms yet,
and that's where I would like
to see this implemented,
but I can talk about a couple of
different experiences
that we've had in
implementing on more classical
network-centric platforms.
So, if we've implemented in
an emerging programmable
software router,
or switch architecture called P4,
we've done it on other
network processor platforms,
and also looked at
virtual switching platforms
that are very common
in data centers.
For example,
everything in Azure is
running on top of
a virtual switch,
so you can imagine running
telemetry or monitoring
applications inside
the virtual switch inside
your data centers, and so on.
The cool thing for us is most of
these systems are
already open source,
and our implementation
to us as well.
Okay, so this highlights, again,
this interesting mapping of
the theoretical
construction to practice,
and there we have
to be a little bit
careful about how we
do the implementation.
So, here's our mapping to P4,
and the classical way,
the naive way of
doing it is to say,
the entire data plane goes to P4,
and the only
application estimation
goes to the control plane,
but it turns out
this actually was
not the right thing to do for P4,
especially because
the sketching layer
requires you to do some sort of
a priority queue or
a sorting operation
inside the data plane,
and that turns out to be
beyond the capabilities
of what this P4 hardware
can actually do.
So, what we did was,
as I essentially said,
we made a pragmatic
choice to say well,
we can't do a priority queue or
a sorting operation
in the data plane.
Instead, we'll just sacrifice
a little bit more
communication overhead,
send the raw reports,
the raw data structure to
the control plane and say,
you do the sorting part, I
can't do the sorting part.
So, we have to be
careful about how we
map this computation,
and this was an
interesting exercise that
showed the naive way of
mapping into the hardware and
may not be the optimal way.
So we sort of pushed
the sorting part to
the control plane as well.
But again, this is
a conscious trade-off,
we incur a little bit more
of a communication overhead,
a few megabytes more for
a very large string,
but it's actually feasible
to map into hardware.
So, this is in
the experience with
this re-programmable
switch architecture.
The other thing, actually,
I want to point out is, actually,
we've also implemented it
in software switching or
software router platforms.
Here, this is where
some of the questions
you asked about,
is it possible to compute
these login hashes and
so on, comes into play.
So, it turns out in
this software router
or software switching platforms,
memory is not a problem.
You actually have a lot
of memory on your server.
The problem is really that
the number of times
you touch this packet,
the number of
computations, or number of
cycles per packet,
is what kills you.
So, that's where we
actually realize that look,
we will not be able to
handle line rate computation
using these classical
sketch implementations,
using on this commodity
software switches
on commodity servers.
So, even the classical sort of
the systems tricks like use DPDK,
use kernel bypass, all
of those things are
not sufficient to
solve this problem,
you have to do something
a little bit more rigorous.
There are ways to solve
this problem if you
can do heuristics and so on,
but they're not
elegant solutions.
So, our idea was actually,
we reformulated the sketching
problem for software and
said if we can change
the theory problem slightly
and say, "Hey, look,
I'm willing to sacrifice
a little bit more memory,
but I want a reduce of CPU,"
or "I'm actually willing to
tolerate some delay
in the answer,
and I can wait for
some convergence
before I get an
accurate estimate."
So, we can trade off delays
and trade off more memory,
to actually reduce
the CPU dramatically.
With these sort of tricks,
we actually can get really,
really high rate, like say, 40,
close to 40 gig on
a single core on
a software switching platform
with some additional
heuristics as well.
Again, so the point of
this is to say that look,
heuristic sketching
is a great idea,
but if you give me
a particular platform,
I need to spend some systems
engineering and careful,
even theory re-tweaking,
to actually
make it practical for
a particular platform.
So, if I think about
an IoT platform that
has energy constraints or
communication constraints,
I may need to tweak this further.
So, I need to think about,
in an IoT platform, for example,
I imagine most of
the energy actually goes
in the radio layer.
Communication is vertical
and kills the battery
on most of these devices I think.
So we actually have to be
a little bit more cognizant,
maybe CPU and memory
is not the problem,
but communication cost
is the problem,
and we may need to compress
the data structure
further before you send it
to the controller and so on.
I've not done that, that
is speculative. All right.
So, so far I've told you there is
a universal sketch and
at least this preliminary
evidence on a couple of
different platforms
suggests there is
a feasible road-map
to implementing
them and sort of realizing the
theoretical benefits
that it promises.
Now, obviously, one question
is why not just
do custom sketches for
a bunch of different metrics?
Is it actually competitive
versus running a custom sketch
for every single application?
So, we did a number of
trace-driven evaluations
to actually understand,
is a universal sketch
competitive with respect
to a custom sketch for,
say, F1, F2, F3, and
so on, and so forth.
Now, the first result here,
the y-axis is the error rate,
and the x-axis is
different tasks, heavy hitters,
data's detection,
change detection,
entropy, estimation, and so on.
So, we give the same amount
of memory to a custom sketch,
as well as same amount of
memory to a universal sketch,
and we check how much off,
in terms of the error
of this particular
task, you are at.
Of course, we have ground truth
where we can do
exact computations and we
compare it to the ground truth,
and the error gap,
I mean, so, obviously, the
custom sketch is going to do
better because it's
only doing one thing,
it's doing this one thing well,
but the gap is not
obscenely high.
The gap is around like
less than four-person,
which is something tolerable
given this amount of memory.
So, notice that if you actually
give what I'm doing here,
is slightly unfair to
universal sketching
because if I built
a system with four tasks,
I would need to do 600 plus
600 plus 600 plus 600,
2400 MB for the
customer algorithm,
but universal sketch only
gets 600 KB overall.
So, it's a little bit
of an unfair comparison
to universal sketch in this case.
Now, here's a more
interesting result,
is what happens when I don't
have just a single app,
but I have a portfolio of
different estimation
applications I care about.
This is where things get
interesting, where let's say,
if I compare against
the portfolio of applications,
and we try different
portfolios Appset1,
Appset2 and Appset3
on the x-axis,
and you actually realize,
you see that as the
application portfolio grows,
there is a clear win
for universal sketch.
In fact, the accuracy of a
universal sketch becomes
better because it's
actually getting
more memory across the portfolio.
It's better to use
the memory with
the universal sketch
than fragmented
for individual tasks.
Of course, there are
still some tasks on
which custom sketch
is doing better,
but overall, the trend
is in favor of
universal sketch approach.
So, that's where we are in
terms of universal sketches.
Now, there's a whole bunch
of open questions
that I don't know the answers to,
especially if you think
about an IoT environment
or a system-wide environment
where there are multiple sensors,
multiple dimensions,
hierarchical dimensions
of interest and so on.
So, I'll sort of briefly
define those problems
and say I don't actually know
the answers to these problems.
So, in a more general
system-wide setting,
you can think of the data
you are getting, actually,
is a high-dimensional data
flowing through your network.
>> [inaudible].
>> That is typically
for one dimension.
Yeah. So, think about like
uni-dimensional dataset
that's flowing
through your system.
So, now you can think about
a high-dimensional
data stream where,
say, even in the network case,
you have IP address,
destination address,
source address,
destination address, source
port, destination port,
protocol and so on, there's
like five dimensions already,
and you can think about
a sensor deployment where
you're collecting many more
dimensions of interest.
In the more general case,
you actually have a number
of these sensing locations.
You have many nodes and many
dimensions of interest.
Now the question then becomes,
how do I actually map
this multi-dimensional problem
and spacial-temporal
problem to this setting.
Now, a trivial assertions
solution might be to place
every sketch for every
single dimension on
every single node,
but that's obviously not
the most optimal thing
you can do.
We can do a little bit better,
so we actually showed
where we can do a
little bit better in terms of
placement and coordination
across the sketches,
at least for one
where the case of the number
of dimensions is small.
A more open question is,
when you get to the
multi-dimensional question,
you may be able to exploit
some kind of
hierarchical structure
in the data to
actually do better,
and we're not doing any
of that stuff right
now in the
multi-dimensional problem.
The holy grail here
is to think about
having one global monitor that
all the data goes through,
and can I get the equivalent
accuracy of having
all the data streaming
through one global node,
even though I have
a system-wide deployment.
I don't quite know
how to do that yet.
That's the holy grail of
this system-wide placement
and analytics problem.
>> So that's where
we are in terms of
universal sketching.
I actually think that it
is a very cool primitive
that can have
very broad applications
not just in networking but
also in the IOT domain,
especially going
forward where there's
going to be many diverse tasks
and many different kinds
of estimates you
actually want to do.
And this could actually be a
fundamental building block
of how you build
future analytics or
telemetric capabilities
for IOT and so on.
I actually briefly touched
upon a couple of other areas
that are relevant to
this workshop agenda.
One is talking about
some interesting machine
learning problems
at the intersection
of machine learning
and IOT security and privacy.
I have to talk about
some of these problems.
I also talk a little bit about
this new large initiative
we are launching at
CMU called CONIX,
which is talking about
a broader umbrella
for many of these different
open problems in general.
So, again, a set of
interesting- again,
this is not meant to
be comprehensive but
just to pique your interest about
interesting problems
or applications of
machine learning to security and
privacy in this particular space.
So I'm interested in looking at,
can we model the behavior
of an IOT device
and automatically
extract a behavioral model for
what a normal behavior of
an IOT device is going to be.
So the motivation here is many of
the high-profile hacks and
many of the high-profile
incidents we see
today as somebody who
went and broke into
your IOT device.
There's a camera there,
somebody hacked into the camera
and maybe my stream is
going out somewhere else.
Now, one question is, well,
these IOT devices are not
general-purpose computers.
So, somebody using them as
general purpose computer is
a behavioral aberration from
the normal expected behavior of
a thermostat or
a camera and so on.
So, the question then
becomes can we build
robust behavioral models that
capture the footprint
of an IOT device?
And use it to flag for
security violations and so on?
Now, the challenge, of course,
is how do I do it in
the presence of
noisy and unlabeled data?
So there's a disconnect
between machine learning
and security in general.
So, machine learning typically
assumes that you have
somebody's nicely
gave you a labeled data
set at least
many classical
formulations of it though.
In security, we actually don't
have these labels, and often,
it's an adversarial
setting where you
also need to worry about
the possibility of
an adversary polluting or
actively evading
your classifier and so on.
So, we have some
preliminary ideas here.
We talked about how we can
build a robust representation,
a finite state machine
representation
of different IOT devices
and use that to
flag deviations for
many different kinds of devices.
The idea here is how do we
actually make it robust to
polluted incoming data
and how do we actually
build a compact behavioral
model that's actually
hard for an adversary to aid
in the future and so on.
So, another interesting problem
domain I've been thinking about,
I don't actually have
a pretty slide for it,
but the vision here
is think about,
it really came about
reading a bunch of
news articles, read this.
It turns out if you use a
service like Airbnb or a hotel,
what looks like
a thermostat is actually
a camera or a listening device
that's spying on you.
So, now, the question
then is like, okay,
I'm a user of these services,
I want to be able to walk into
a room and say, hey, look,
and sort of map out the kinds of
sensors and capabilities that
this particular room has,
and say, hey, this camera is
actually listening to me.
That's a thermostat or that
looks like a smoke alarm,
but it's actually
a camera that has
listening capabilities and so on.
So, the idea here
is I should be able
to walk into a room and say,
figure out the capabilities
of individual devices
inside that particular room so
I actually know what
I'm getting into.
If I'm going at Airbnb,
I know what I'm getting
into as a hidden camera
there so maybe I'll be careful
about what I do there.
So, these are interesting
application of machine learning.
You can think about
I can walk in,
I can monitor different
kinds of features.
I can monitor the Wi-Fi,
the Bluetooth,
the energy spectrum.
I can monitor the RF spectrum.
I can monitor visual aids image
and so on and so forth.
I have a bunch of
different features
and I want to be able to say,
hey, this is features,
is that a camera or
is that a thermostat?
That gets a thermostat,
claims to be a thermostat,
looks like a thermostat,
but it's EM footprint
looks like it looks like
a camera or it's Wi-Fi
footprint looks like
a camera. Can I do it?
Maybe I can, and it turns
out there's actually
some interesting
preliminary work by
some other folks from
this paper that they were looking
at and actually
have this data set.
So, those of you looking
at for interesting
IOT smart home data set is
actually seemed like
a nice data set.
They collected traffic emitted
by 31 smart home devices
and very standard traffic
fingerprinting techniques.
Look at the average packet size.
Look at the kind of
protocols,the kind of
codes these particular
devices is sending,
and use that to create a compact
fingerprint and say, hey, look,
if you're sending a lot of
outgoing connections,
you're probably a camera.
Or if you're sending
periodic heartbeats,
you're probably Amazon Alexa
and so on and so forth.
I mean nothing fancy there.
Good question. I
don't know. So, then
maybe after this, put
some other features.
So, the question is what
features can you monitor?
Maybe there's actually
manifestations
in the other parts as well.
Maybe there's an
electromagnetic emissions
I actually manifests even
though it's wired and so on.
Or you can actually
also think about like
actively doing something to see
how they respond to
active request and queries.
I don't know. This is
an open question for me.
Actually, I've been
trying to implement this
using ProtoNN, which
is like a cool
new compact machine
learning algorithm
that you guys have developed.
Actually, over one day,
and Harsha has been helping
me actually get this running.
Results are TBD
because I haven't,
my coding skills are rusty.
All right. So that's
interesting applications
of machine learning
to security and privacy.
Last part, I actually do
want to talk about like
this new big center that
we're actually doing.
Looking at these problems in
a more general perspective,
I talked about monitoring
for telemetry,
interesting applications of IOT
to machine learning and security,
setup a machine-learning
IOT security and
privacy, but more broadly,
the goal here is thinking
about there is a lot of
interesting new next
generation applications
of IOT drones,
self-driving cars, and
so on and so forth that
essentially require
new capabilities
inside the network
from the systems
that we're developing and so on.
So the idea here,
the vision here is
that so there's a whole bunch
of new applications and
unit network
infrastructures that are
going to be
fundamentally changing
the way we need to
rethink how we have done
classic systems design and
machine learning and so on.
So the new network
infrastructure,
and this is the project
called CONIX.
The vision here is there are
going to be extreme scale,
think about smart cities,
pervasive augmented
reality applications
and so on that are going to
have a lot of variability,
heterogeneity,
cool spatiotemporal
context-aware application.
Then they're going to require
low latency communication,
otherwise, their car
is going to crash
and and so on and so forth.
So our work, the goal of
the sector is basically
saying that we can
think about classical paradigms
of billions of edge devices,
the cloud or
the Internet, and so on.
But really none of them are
a good fit for
these emerging class of
applications and we need to
bring some more structure
to this chaos,
and in particular we
actually believe that
the network infrastructure are
the middle of this network,
the middle layer is going to play
a much bigger reward than it's
classically played in the system.
Sorry. So that's a good question.
So one thing about all
self-driving cars are actually
having massive GPUs and
stuff inside the system.
So, think about like can
you make the Tata Nano
a self-driving car?
Can you have a low cost
self-driving car,
but actually the computer
actually back-end?
It's not like we
have bazillions have
GPUs inside your network,
inside a car and so on.
That's one example where
you can think about you can
democratize the ability of
doing it by doing it more.
That's one way of
thinking about it
but low cost is not
the only thing.
That's one sort of natural way
of thinking about it.
Yeah, and the goal here is
the vision of this having
more in-network computational
capabilities as
a natural way of dealing with
a bunch of these different
distributed applications,
and it's again given
that the cloud and the edge
are both had to change,
the network actually might
be the way to do things.
So, again, this is
not a single systems
or a machine learning
or a hardware problem.
It's really a cross-cutting
problem where, as I said,
there's a very diverse team from
multiple universities we're
working towards this vision.
You're looking at machine
learning for resilience,
building these trustworthy
computation systems from scratch,
safe secure and
smart programming.
Building cool new spatio-temporally
aware applications,
better in-network coordination
and control mechanisms,
as well as new
hardware architectures
and maybe even some of
the compact machine
learning algorithms
that can run at the edge
and so on again.
We're in early days,
it's really less than six months
since we launched.
So this is a long-term effort
that we're actually
launching right now.
So research fellows or other
people in this room who are
applying for grad school,
we are hiring aggressively.
Cool. That's it. I'm done